okay so it's time for my predictions for
2019 but before I get into my crystal
ball let's remind ourselves of while I
guess would happen this time last year I
see Brenda from Bristol can you see
looking upset again as we have another
general election this is my won't be
Prime Minister after it I see an old
bloke with gray hair moving into number
10 now it's not unique I think it'll be
Jeremy Corbyn but he won't have an
overall majority so he'll be there as
the leader of an anti hard brexit
alliance
I see tens of thousands of people
protesting against the visit of
President Trump out on the streets
I see England getting to the final eight
of the World Cup I think our very own
Michelle DubLi will finally meet mr.
Vyse
forget Mystic Meg as you can see with
the exception of England's run to the
World Cup semi-finals and the inevitable
protests against President Trump
manlihood last year was pretty grim so
first prediction for 2019 here we go
again
the return of mystique make we won't be
leaving the EU at the end of March I
believe Parliament not necessarily the
government would decide to extend
article 50 secondly there will be a
second referendum in 2019 the people's
vote will happen and horror of Horrors
the Daily Mail or support staying in the
EU
I don't believe Mrs May will be prime
minister this time next year and more
controversially I think Jeremy Corbyn
will also be on his bike by next
December now I know everyone has had the
b-word up to here so apologies if my
predictions are dominated by Beck's it
but I'm not going to risk betting on
this love life
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes I think you're onto something last
year you did look an absolute fool admit
God knows if we're all still alive what
they'll do with you in 2019 okay so uh
number one Britain won't leave the EU
it's an act of Parliament on the 29th of
March next year but unless you're
telling me they've got time to vote in
another act of Parliament to hope stop
the oponent that's all really think you
know that Parliament can unilaterally
revoke article 15 which means we can
pause and then have time to do think
that would be the most dangerous thing
yeah no no we're not what you think
that's what I think is going to happen
because I don't think there's a majority
for any option in Parliament and
therefore I think they will have to pull
do you think there's a majority for
anything in the country well yes that's
what I'm saying I'm saying about if you
have a second referendum what the result
is no I think you should I think if I
did I think it will be 52 48 the other
way but I think you're absolutely well I
think we will be leaving the EU I do not
think there'll be a second referendum I
think we will leave with a No Deal
scenario and and I think at the very end
up I think you're right about Korbin I
think he'd be a Tony's here this time
next year I think Mrs May will still be
there I don't want it to be but I think
she will be and I did and I think I
think if we say we're leaving with a No
Deal I predict that the EU at the
eleventh hour will give us a kind of
deal I think you draw on every single I
think I think well I kind of wish Greg
had predicted something like what Carol
st. given you a track record I would
like which is the second referendum
which I think with my educating Glyn to
the semi to the court the glimmer of
hope I mean I do know I agree I don't
think we'll be leaving this year I don't
think there are enough reasonable
gung-ho people in this country to hold
our economic future to ransom to go out
on a No Deal scenario I just don't think
there are enough people who would be
willing to take that kind of risk with
our country especially since the people
who wanted breakfast
sorry this has to be done the ones who
supposedly care most about the future
this country and it's me don't worry as
thing we just didn't accept your
scenario well I don't accept your snart
I mean you know this is prediction so
I'm not saying what I want to happen is
what's going to happen but I just don't
think that in three months time we'll be
leaving so I think I hope well I'm
Scrooge and Scrooge you remember he had
some terrible dreams but none of them
gonna be as bad as crashing out without
a deal I think now I think the dream is
terrifying I think should we broaden it
out you don't think it'll be mrs. Mayer
you don't think it'd be Jeremy Corbyn
those are like your third and fourth but
it is basically a plexi tear leading a
remain apart yes and that's not as the
prime minister as a remainder so who
will be at the helm who will be the hell
yeah the country will be the Prime
Minister oh I think there will be a
conservative Prime Minister do you have
any idea who might that be
it's believer or a remaining I think it
would be one of about fearful remain
yeah you see because Greg doesn't think
bricks it is gonna happen the remaining
money in the box in the job but I'm
gonna make another prediction which has
got nothing to do with politics I think
Kate Middleton will happen as a baby
next year okay let's come I don't know
what I'm gonna make a prediction I think
Megan Marco is gonna have a baby next
we'll have to apologize to me when we've
left European unity by this time next
year we'll be doing okay you will say
you were right you say I was right that
we were gonna crash out all that it was
a good exit ears don't think I've told I
remember clashing with Ken Livingstone
who was a very famous mayor of London
who introduced the congestion zone into
London and I know there are people who
just remind them there wasn't buddy
and I came in and we had a really
full-on round we actually got on fine
personally and then when I've told this
story before when the red light went off
and therefore he was able to talk Ken
livers and said mmm
in reality and I think the same applies
it it won't be as great as Ken well as
great as I think it's gonna be and it
won't be as bad as you think it's gonna
be as with all things it will be
somewhere in the middle and I think
we're not going to crash out yeah me
neither
let's ask one more prediction from each
not about breaks it does give Kate
middles and I think it's gonna happen
baby might come back to me I'm thinking
about it positive one
England's cricket continues to triumph
and Alastair we miss alistair cooke and
he gets his night at which is fantastic
yeah Jose marine Jose Jose Mourinho will
return and lead Chelsea I don't know I'd
like to take a side bet on that it's
been another crazy topsy-turvy 12 months
we on the pledge have done our best to
make sense of it all but it's safe to
say that our attempts to analyze and
explain what's going on have not always
been successful you're gonna so enjoy
this guys having
[Music]
the UK's Department with international
development works in developed deprived
areas of complete managers fault it's
the bloody soldier someone excuse Malone
we've RESP took so long to make it
[Applause]
[Music]
impressive theory is male that could be
holding someone I don't know
[Music]
it's worse than Carol I sneezed in my
I've got a bad back
hope you bit that's hope that three two
one
[Music]
what a yeah well can you apologize for
your potty mouth
it's terrible ordered so badly up there
that's it for this episode this season
and even this year of the pledge it's
been a blast thanks for watching
Merry Christmas
[Music]
you
you